[Music]
you moved to the u.s. at the age of
seven from Russia were you living in
Moscow at the time no I was living in
Ukraine you're living in Ukraine yeah
you moved at the age of seven and your
parents they didn't really tell you that
you were moving the United States is
that right correct my parents took it
upon themselves to lie to me and and
tell me we're moving up the street so Oh
laughs laughs you guys it's great yeah I
was seven and I was like these boxes
doing here and my mom was like oh we're
going to move up the street and I was
like I love that she a spy too in old
movies that's always how the spy talks
yeah yes I was like oh we're moving up
the street and then one day we weren't
moving up the street she we were on a
train and I was like whoa we're on a
train what are we going this is a long
street you lived it and then we got to
Moscow and then we got on a plane and
all of that was very new to me like a
train was new the plane was new I had
coca-cola for the first time I mean like
the entire experience was very nice why
did they not tell you was it just it was
overwhelming or was it were they afraid
did they kind of want to slip out yeah
you kind of wasn't is there like you
want to slip out you just don't want
people to know like you at that point it
was still like at the fall of communism
and we came in a refugee visa it just
wasn't something you flaunted right so
it was just like let's keep it quiet and
if we tell me my loud-ass daughter yeah
clearly don't say around all your
friends like I'm done with you the
mankind
[Laughter]
that's not cool what America was I was
like what could I have done and they're
like said the word America and well
that's true probably the right call I
think that's right
you